From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hello, I'm Paul Lalonde. You see, the world you're sitting in right now is a completely different world than the one I'm sitting in recording this message. An event the Bible calls the Rapture has taken place, and millions or even billions of people have vanished from the face of the Earth, including myself and all of the men you're going to see on this video today. You know, while we can't begin to imagine what the world you're sitting in right now must be like, we can at least say we knew this was going to happen, and we can answer many of the questions that are so important to you right now.
你好，我是保罗·拉隆德。你看，你现在所处的这个世界，与我录制这条信息时所处的世界完全不同。一件圣经中称为“被提”的事件已经发生，数百万甚至数十亿人已经从地球上消失，包括我在内，也包括你今天在这个视频中看到的所有人。你知道，虽然我们无法想象你现在所处的那个世界是什么样子，但我们至少可以说，我们预料到会发生这种事，并且我们能解答你现在非常关心的许多问题。
This is a video called Left Behind , and it exists to solve a problem. In the view of evangelical and fundamentalist Christians who try to understand the prophecies in the Bible, we as a species are on the verge of some terrible events, events that will usher in the end of time and the return of Jesus to the Earth. But the very first thing that will happen at the start of these times, according to these Christians, according to the Bible, is that good Christians will be lifted away to Heaven in an instant. That's what they call the Rapture.
这是一个名为《末日迷踪》的视频，它的存在是为了解决一个问题。在试图解读圣经预言的福音派和基要派基督徒眼中，我们这个物种正处于一些可怕事件的边缘，这些事件将预示着末日的到来和耶稣重返地球。但根据这些基督徒的说法，根据圣经的记载，在这些时代开始时，首先会发生的事情就是虔诚的基督徒将瞬间被提升到天堂。这就是他们所说的“被提”。
This video and others like it are designed to explain to those left behind exactly what's occurred and what happens after the Christians are all gone.
这个视频以及类似的作品，旨在向那些被留下的人解释究竟发生了什么，以及在基督徒全部消失后会发生什么。
I would assume that there's a lot of fear, there's a lot of tension. I would assume that newscasters are speculating as to the disappearance of millions and millions of people on planet Earth. You are wondering what's going to take place next. I would refer you to the Bible. The Bibles are still left, all over the world--
我想一定会有很多恐惧和紧张气氛。我想新闻主播们一定在推测地球上数以百万计的人为何消失。你一定想知道接下来会发生什么。我建议你去读圣经。圣经仍然留在世界各地——
Well, the true believers have just been taken out, as those crazy Christians used to tell you they would. And they've all been suddenly, without warning, snatched out to meet Christ in the air, and they've been changed from mortal to immortal.
好吧，真正的信徒已经被带走了，就像那些疯狂的基督徒曾经告诉你的那样。他们都在毫无预警的情况下突然被抓走去空中迎接基督，从必死之身变成了不朽之身。
Much of this videotape is a warning. It says that after the Christians all vanish, there will be seven years of tribulation with a false prophet, an antichrist. The video tries to warn us against all of the lies that the antichrist will tell, but it's very tricky business because the people putting together the videotape do not know what exactly the lies will be.
这段录像的大部分内容是一个警告。它说在基督徒全部消失后，将会有七年的大灾难，伴随着假先知和敌基督。视频试图警告我们提防敌基督所说的所有谎言，但这非常棘手，因为制作这段录像的人并不知道那些谎言具体会是什么。
And as we sit and ponder that, we think about if the rapture took place in the world in which we live today, the one frame of reference that most people would have for this event came from something that's been very popular in this world for the last decade or so. It's called Star Trek. And it's called the transporter beam. "Beam me up, Scotty." So stories will begin to explode that people have been taken off this planet on UFOs, that they've been sent to other planets, to slave planets, or that they have just been brought up to a UFO for some reason or another. This is simply not true, according to the Scripture. It is a lie that we know is forthcoming.
当我们坐下来思考这个问题时，我们想，如果“被提”发生在我们今天生活的世界中，大多数人对这一事件的唯一参考框架来自过去十年左右在这个世界上非常流行的东西。它叫《星际迷航》，也就是传送光束。“斯科特，把我传上去。”所以，关于人们被外星人劫持，被送往其他星球、奴隶星球，或者因某种原因被带到UFO上的谣言将开始爆发。根据圣经，这些完全不是真的。这是我们已知即将出现的谎言。
There's a kind of Left Behind industry churning out product right now. A series of novels about what will happen after the Rapture during the years of tribulation predicted by the Bible has crossed over from the Christian bestseller list to the mainstream charts. The latest book in the series is at number seven on the New York Times Bestseller list this week. It sold a half million copies in its first two weeks. The other four books in the series plus the videos plus the audio books plus the special series about the end time for young people called Left Behind For Kids together have sold about 6 million copies, according to the publisher.
现在有一种“末日迷踪”产业正在源源不断地生产产品。一系列关于“被提”后在大灾难期间会发生什么的系列小说，已经从基督教畅销书榜跨越到了主流榜单。该系列中的最新一本书本周在《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上排名第七。它在前两周就售出了五十万册。据出版商称，该系列的其他四本书，加上视频、有声读物，以及为年轻人制作的关于末日的特别系列《儿童版末日迷踪》，总共已经售出了约600万册。
And if you don't think that the people in your life believe in these prophecies, just ask around. In an informal poll of the people who work at this public radio station where I speak to you from right now, WBEZ in Chicago, nine people out of the 55 that we asked said they do believe in the biblical prophecies of the Rapture and the end time. And yet, this is an area where religious people and secular people definitely do not see eye to eye. Secular people, non-Christians, usually do not take these beliefs very seriously. In this hour today, we try to demonstrate why they should.
如果你认为你生活中的人并不相信这些预言，试着问问他们。在我们现在向你播音的这家公共广播电台WBEZ芝加哥站，在接受调查的55名员工中，有9人表示他们确实相信关于“被提”和末日的圣经预言。然而，这是一个宗教人士和世俗人士绝对无法达成共识的领域。世俗人士、非基督徒，通常不会太认真对待这些信仰。在今天这个小时里，我们试着证明为什么他们应该认真对待。
Our subject today, the end of the world. Act One, Cowboys of the Apocalypse, the true story of fundamentalist Christians uniting in a project with orthodox Jews to create a cow that could bring about the end of the world. Act Two, the Cost of Misunderstanding, an explanation of why an FBI agent might want to pack a Bible along with his gun. Act Three, Again. Writer Sarah Vowell has seen the end of the world not once, not twice, but three times. And she is back to tell the tale. Act Four, None Shall Know the Exact Hour or Time, in which we answer the question, what do the dates October 22, 1844, May 21, 1999, and September 11, 1999, what do those dates have in common? We have answers coming up. Stay with us.
我们今天的主题是世界末日。第一幕，“启示录的牛仔”，一群基要派基督徒与正统犹太人联合起来，通过一个项目试图培育出能带来世界末日的母牛的真实故事。第二幕，“误解的代价”，解释为什么一名联邦调查局探员会想要在枪旁边放一本圣经。第三幕，“重来”，作家萨拉·沃威尔不是一次、两次，而是三次见证了世界末日，她回来讲述这个故事。第四幕，“无人知晓确切的时辰”，我们将回答一个问题：1844年10月22日、1999年5月21日和1999年9月11日这些日期有什么共同点？答案即将揭晓，请继续收听。
Act One, Cowboys of the Apocalypse. Clyde Lott was a man with two main interests, cows-- he was a cattle breeder by profession-- and the Bible. He's also an evangelical minister. And one day, he was doing something that combined his two interests. Lawrence Wright wrote about him in The New Yorker magazine.
第一幕，启示录的牛仔。克莱德·洛特是一个有两种主要爱好的人：母牛——他职业是养牛户，以及圣经。他也是一位福音派牧师。有一天，他正在做一件结合了他这两个爱好的事情。劳伦斯·赖特在《纽约客》杂志上写过他。
He was going through the Bible and looking for all the references about cows. The early books of the Bible are essentially about an agricultural people, so there are a lot of references about cattle. And when he came upon Numbers 19, he found this reference. When God was speaking to Moses, God commanded that Moses tell his people to bring him a red heifer without spot or blemish, and it would be sacrificed to him.
他当时正在研读圣经，寻找所有关于母牛的记载。圣经早期的书卷本质上是关于农业民族的，所以有很多关于牛的记载。当他读到《民数记》第19章时，他发现了这个记载。当上帝对摩西说话时，上帝命令摩西告诉他的人民，为他献上一头没有残疾、没有瑕疵的红母牛，并将它献祭给他。
And Clyde began to wonder where they might have gotten such a cow, because all of the cattle that he could find referenced in the Old Testament were spotted or striped. But what he also knew is that there's a breed of cattle call the Red Angus that's as red as an Irish Setter. And it seems to be unknown in the Middle East. So it struck him that he might be the very man who could bring the red heifer back to the land of Israel.
克莱德开始纳闷他们从哪里弄来这种牛，因为他能在旧约中找到记载的所有牛都是有斑点或条纹的。但他还知道有一种叫红安格斯牛的品种，红得就像一只爱尔兰雪达犬。而且这种牛在中东似乎不为人知。所以他灵机一动，觉得自己或许正是能把红母牛带回以色列土地的那个人。
Now, there's an important reason Clyde Lott might want to do that, and that reason involves biblical prophecy. In Clyde Lott's reading of the Bible-- and many people see it this way-- the second coming of Jesus, Armageddon, the Rapture, the thousand-year reign of Jesus on Earth, all this will occur only after three things happen. Number one, the establishment of the state of Israel. Number two, Jerusalem has to be in Jewish hands. And number three, the ancient Jewish temple in Jerusalem, a temple that was destroyed in 79 AD, that temple has to be rebuilt and reestablished as the center of Jewish worship.
现在，克莱德·洛特想要这样做有一个重要的原因，这个原因涉及圣经预言。在克莱德·洛特对圣经的解读中——许多人也这么认为——耶稣的第二次降临、哈米吉多顿、被提、耶稣在地球上的一千年统治，所有这一切都只会发生在三件事之后。第一，以色列国的建立。第二，耶路撒冷必须掌握在犹太人手中。第三，古代耶路撒冷的犹太圣殿，那座在公元79年被毁的圣殿，必须被重建并恢复为犹太崇拜的中心。
Now, numbers one and two, of course, have come to pass in the last few decades. But to reestablish the ancient Jewish temple, somebody would first have to purify the ground for the temple, and then they would have to purify the temple itself. And to do that, according to the Bible, somebody would have to sacrifice a pure Numbers 19 red heifer without spot or blemish. Where would a cow like that come from? Clyde Lott turned the question over and over in his head, until one day in the summer of 1990.
当然，第一和第二点在过去几十年里已经实现了。但要重建古代犹太圣殿，首先得有人为圣殿净化土地，然后他们必须净化圣殿本身。根据圣经，要做到这一点，需要有人牺牲一头符合《民数记》第19章要求的、没有瑕疵和斑点的纯红母牛。这样的牛从哪里来？克莱德·洛特脑子里不断琢磨这个问题，直到1990年夏天的某一天。
Well, he was out baling hay and his baler broke. And he started to go into town to get a new part, and he found himself, he said, driving instead to Jackson, Mississippi, the capital, and walked into the Department of Agriculture.
当时他正在打草捆，打草机坏了。他本想进城去买零件，却发现自己开车去了首府密西西比州的杰克逊，走进了农业部。
And I can remember walking into his office straight out of the hayfield--
我还记得我直接从草场走进他的办公室——
This is Clyde Lott.
这是克莱德·洛特。
--with blue jeans, Wal-Mart tennis shoes, baseball cap, dirty, smelly, hay and grass all over me, grease on me, and asking the question, or stating the fact and then asking the question, where did Israel get their red cow from? And you could imagine his response for the first few minutes.
——穿着牛仔裤，穿着沃尔玛买的网球鞋，戴着棒球帽，浑身脏兮兮的，臭烘烘的，满身干草和草屑，手上沾着油垢，然后提出了那个问题，或者说先陈述了一个事实，然后问：以色列的红牛是从哪儿来的？你可以想象他头几分钟的反应。
Yeah, what was his response? Was he like, well, you're the third person in here today asking me this?
是的，他的反应是什么？他是说“好吧，你是今天第三个来问我这个问题的人”吗？
No. He looked at me for several minutes before he realized that I was serious.
不。他盯着我看了好几分钟，才意识到我是认真的。
When this official realized Mr. Lott was serious, he helped him write a letter that made its way from one US government official to another until finally it was forwarded to a private organization in Israel called the Temple Institute. The Temple Institute is run by very religious Jews whose goal is, as you might expect, to reestablish the ancient temple in Jerusalem.
当这位官员意识到洛特先生是认真的，他帮他写了一封信，这封信从一个美国政府官员手中转到另一个官员手中，最后被转交给以色列的一家名为“圣殿研究所”的私人组织。圣殿研究所由非常虔诚的犹太人运营，正如你所料，他们的目标是重建耶路撒冷的古代圣殿。
They want to do this because it's the belief of some Jews that to be truly Jewish, you have to obey all the commandments in the Bible. And it turns out that about a third of those commandments are specifically about things that happened at that original temple. Also, many orthodox Jews believe that the Messiah, the Jewish Messiah who's been awaited for millennia, cannot arrive until the temple is rebuilt. And it turns out that the rabbis at the temple institute had been pondering the question of where they were going to find a Numbers 19 red heifer without blemish or spot. And so naturally they were very interested to talk with Mr. Lott. After some letters and phone calls, he flew to meet with them in Jerusalem.
他们想这样做，是因为一些犹太人相信，要成为真正的犹太人，就必须遵守圣经中的所有诫命。事实证明，这些诫命中约有三分之一是专门关于在原始圣殿中发生的事情的。此外，许多正统犹太人相信，等待了数千年的犹太弥赛亚，在圣殿重建之前是不会到来的。事实证明，圣殿研究所的拉比们一直在思考去哪里寻找一头符合《民数记》第19章要求的、没有瑕疵和斑点的红母牛。所以自然地，他们非常有兴趣与洛特先生交谈。在几封信和几次电话后，他飞往耶路撒冷去见他们。
What they put into motion was a project that now involves dozens of people, volunteers, cattlemen, many Christian and Jewish donors, and very high-tech, 20th-century breeding techniques all to create a Red Angus that would conform to biblical law and also thrive in the heat of the Mideast. From the very start, Clyde Lott says, they found they had a lot to talk about. Though, coming from his part of Mississippi, he had never really talked much with many Jews.
他们启动了一个项目，现在涉及几十人、志愿者、牧牛人、许多基督教和犹太捐赠者，以及非常高科技的20世纪育种技术，所有这些都是为了培育出一头既符合圣经律法，又能适应中东炎热气候的红安格斯牛。从一开始，克莱德·洛特说，他们发现有很多共同语言。尽管来自密西西比州，他之前从未真正与许多犹太人交谈过。
In meeting with Rabbi Ariel and meeting with Rabbi Richman, we began to talk about producing cows, red cows for Numbers 19. And Rabbi Richman was interpreting for Rabbi Ariel. And one of the things that they had asked us was, how many cows did we think it would take to produce a Numbers 19 red heifer? And we told him we thought that it would take approximately 200 head. And what was amazing there, then, was they asked us how much they thought it would cost. And we told Rabbi Richman $2,000 a head. And he turned to Rabbi Ariel and told him $20,000. There was a mistake.
在与阿里尔拉比和里奇曼拉比会面时，我们开始谈论生产《民数记》第19章所需的红牛。里奇曼拉比在为阿里尔拉比做翻译。他们问我们的其中一件事是，我们认为需要多少头母牛才能产下一头《民数记》第19章要求的红母牛？我们告诉他，我们认为大约需要200头。令人惊讶的是，他们问我们认为这要花多少钱。我们告诉里奇曼拉比每头2000美元。他转身告诉阿里尔拉比2万美元。出错了。
He told him that in Hebrew?
他用希伯来语告诉他的？
Yes. Yes, he was speaking to Rabbi Ariel in Hebrew. And you can imagine the next few minutes got pretty excited between those two rabbis, because that was quite a sum of money when you figure 200 head at $20,000 a head.
是的。是的，他当时正用希伯来语跟阿里尔拉比说话。你可以想象那两位拉比接下来几分钟变得非常激动，因为考虑到200头牛，每头2万美元，那可是一笔巨款。
And after several minutes of listening to them talk back and forth, we interrupted Rabbi Richman, and we asked him what the problem was. And he said, well, $20,000 is a lot of money for these cows. And we made the statement and said simply this, that we're not trying to take advantage of you as you're seeking to turn back to God.
在听了他们来回交谈几分钟后，我们打断了里奇曼拉比，问他出了什么问题。他说，好吧，2万美元对这些牛来说是一笔巨款。我们陈述并简单地说，我们并不是试图在你们寻求回归上帝的过程中占你们的便宜。
And they were astonished because there was a parable in Jewish tradition about a Gentile who was a jeweler. And a jewel had fallen out of the vest of the chief rabbi. And a delegation had gone down to this jeweler who was supposed to replace this precious stone. And they asked him how much it would cost to replace. And he said it was 100 shekels, but he couldn't replace it at present because the box with the precious jewels was under the bed where his father was sleeping and he didn't want to disturb him. And they thought that was a ruse, so they raised the price and doubled it and then doubled it. And finally it got up to 1,000 shekels and he still refused. And the delegation left very angrily.
他们非常惊讶，因为犹太传统中有一个关于珠宝商异教徒的寓言。一颗宝石从大拉比的背心中掉落。一个代表团去找这个本应更换珍贵宝石的珠宝商。他们问更换它要花多少钱。他说要100舍客勒，但他目前无法更换，因为装珍贵宝石的盒子在他父亲睡觉的床下，他不想打扰他。他们认为这是一种诡计，所以他们把价格提高了一倍，又翻了一倍。最后达到了1000舍客勒，他依然拒绝。代表团愤怒地离开了。
And shortly thereafter, according to the story, Dama ben Natina's father awoke and retrieved the jewel and ran down the road and gave it to the priest. And they in turn gave him the 1,000 shekels. And he gave them back 900, correcting the price to 1/10, the same thing that we did. And as soon as he gave back the 900 shekels, he made the statement that I'm not trying to take advantage of you as you seek to turn to God, word for word, the same thing that we said almost 2,000-plus years later.
据故事记载，不久之后，达马·本·纳蒂纳的父亲醒了，取回了宝石，跑下路交给了祭司。他们反过来给了他1000舍客勒。他退还了900舍客勒，将价格纠正为原来的十分之一，这正是我们近2000多年后所做的事。
And right there on the road, the priest of the temple prayed a blessing over this man. And the blessing was that out of his Gentile lineage one day would come the producer of the red heifer. So the rabbis of the temple saw a striking similarity between the two. And it really went a long way to establish our relationship with them.
就在那条路上，圣殿的祭司为这个人祈求祝福。祝福的内容是，在他的外邦血统中，有一天会出一位红母牛的生产者。所以圣殿的拉比们看到了两者之间惊人的相似之处。这真的在建立我们与他们的关系方面起到了很大作用。
Do you believe that you are descended from that man?
你相信你是那个人的后裔吗？
I have no idea. But what I believe is very simply that we have been called by God to perform a needed function in the life of Israel.
我不知道。但我相信的是，我们被上帝召唤去在以色列的生活中履行一项必要的功能。
So when are the first cows going to be flown to Israel?
那么第一批母牛什么时候会被运到以色列？
We hope possibly as early as May. If not May, we feel like that it will be October, November.
我们希望最早在五月。如果不是五月，我们觉得也会在十月或十一月。
And how many cows do you think are going to be in that first group?
你认为第一批会有多少头母牛？
We hope to fly over approximately 300 head of heifers and 15 to 20 bulls.
我们希望用飞机运送大约300头小母牛和15到20头公牛。
And then how is that done? What kind of plane does this?
那是怎么操作的？用什么样的飞机运？
A 747. There are a number of planes that fly cattle, but we are working with a 747.
波音747。有很多飞机可以运载牛，但我们正与波音747合作。
You know, that's not the only group of cows. There's apparently some cattle that are being bred in Texas as well. So I think that the chances of a red heifer being born in Israel that meets all the requirements within the next several months is pretty strong. I can't stress too strongly what a catastrophic thing it would be from a political and diplomatic point of view.
你知道，那不是唯一的一群牛。显然德克萨斯州也在培育一些牛。所以我认为在未来几个月内以色列出生一头符合所有要求的红母牛的可能性非常大。从政治和外交角度来看，我怎么强调这是一件灾难性的事情都不为过。
It would be catastrophic, says Lawrence Wright, because once there was a red heifer, Jews and Christians would certainly start to agitate for the rebuilding of the ancient Jewish temple, and agitate hard. A small portion of that temple still exists in Israel today, the Western Wall. You can see it if you go to Jerusalem. But to rebuild the temple in its original form on its original site, which is the only thing that would be acceptable under Jewish law, most people believe that you would have to tear down two holy Islamic sites that stand near the Western Wall, the Al-Aqsa Mosque and the Dome of the Rock. The Dome of the Rock is the oldest building in Islam and one of its holiest sites. Muslims believe that it was from this spot that Muhammad ascended to Heaven on his winged steed.
劳伦斯·赖特说，这将是灾难性的，因为一旦有了红母牛，犹太人和基督徒肯定会开始强烈要求重建古代犹太圣殿。那座圣殿的一小部分今天仍然存在于以色列，就是西墙。如果你去耶路撒冷就能看到它。但要在原址上以原始形式重建圣殿，这在犹太律法下是唯一可接受的，大多数人认为你必须拆除西墙附近的两座神圣伊斯兰建筑：阿克萨清真寺和圆顶清真寺。圆顶清真寺是伊斯兰教最古老的建筑，也是其最神圣的地点之一。穆斯林相信穆罕默德就是从这里骑着有翼坐骑升天的。
I think that it's extremely likely that one of two things will happen. Either some religious group will succeed in destroying or severely damaging one or both of the mosques on top of the temple mount. Or else the extreme religious, political wing that is so ascendant in Israel now will gain enough power to decide to remove the mosque and reestablish the temple. And I think it would be an unmitigated diplomatic catastrophe, and that it would excite a religious war such as we haven't seen since the Crusades.
我认为发生以下两件事之一的可能性极大。要么某个宗教团体成功摧毁或严重损坏了圣殿山上的清真寺中的一座或两座。要么以色列现在处于上升期的极端宗教政治派别将获得足够的权力，决定拆除清真寺并重建圣殿。我认为这将是一场绝对的外交灾难，它将激起一场自十字军东征以来我们从未见过的宗教战争。
Really?
真的吗？
Well, you know, it is--
嗯，你知道，它是——
I was with you up until that very last sentence.
在你说最后那句话之前，我都同意你的观点。
I can't underscore too strongly how tense this situation is and how jealously the Muslim authorities guard this. Just a few years ago, there's a little tunnel that runs alongside the temple mount. And as a tourist, you can go walk along. You see these immense and quite beautiful stones that were fashioned under King Herod. And the Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu decided to extend that tunnel so that people could walk all the way through without doubling back, so people could pass freely out into the street. And that itself was regarded with such suspicion that there were riots all over Jerusalem and the West Bank. 90 people died.
我怎么强调这种情况的紧张程度以及穆斯林当局对这里的严密保护都不为过。就在几年前，圣殿山旁边有一条小隧道。作为游客，你可以走过去。你会看到这些在希律王时期建造的巨大而美丽的石头。总理本雅明·内塔尼亚胡决定延长那条隧道，以便人们无需折返就能全程走完，这样人们就可以自由地走到街上。这本身就被视为一种极大的挑衅，导致整个耶路撒冷和西岸爆发了骚乱。90人死亡。
Just to build these tunnels for tourists?
仅仅是为了给游客建这些隧道？
Just to open the tunnel to the street.
只是为了把隧道通到街道。
90 people died over that?
90人因为这个死了？
90 people died for that.
90人为此而死。
We've been accused of-- once cows getting over there-- starting World War III. And in fact, I've even been accused of being the antichrist.
我们被指控——一旦牛运到那里——将引发第三次世界大战。事实上，我甚至被指控是敌基督。
Wow. Do you worry that perhaps one of the things that could happen, though, once red heifers are reintroduced to Israel, that it could lead to violence of one sort or another?
哇。你是否担心，红母牛一旦被重新引入以色列，可能会导致某种形式的暴力事件？
This is a faith walk with us. And when we commit our life to a walk of faith, we are committing our complete trust in God to do with us as he sees fit to accomplish his end. So from that standpoint, I have never been worried about the outcome because I know beyond a shadow of a doubt that the outcome is going to be the outcome that God wants.
这对我们来说是一场信心之旅。当我们致力于信仰之路时，我们是全心全意地相信上帝会按照他认为合适的方式处理我们，以完成他的目标。所以从这个角度来看，我从不担心结果，因为我毫无疑问地知道，结果将是上帝想要的结果。
You're lucky to have that kind of faith.
你很幸运拥有那样的信仰。
Well, we as Christians all should exercise this kind of faith.
嗯，我们作为基督徒都应该践行这种信仰。
You quote this incredible statistic, poll number, in your article where you say that about half, 46% of all Americans, believe that the state of Israel in its existence and being held by Jewish hands is the fulfillment of prophecy.
你在文章中引用了一个令人难以置信的统计数据，你说大约一半，46%的美国人相信以色列国的存在及其掌握在犹太人手中是预言的应验。
Right. It's not just fundamentalists. I know a lot of people who would not consider themselves to be fundamentalist who are mainstream Christians who read the Bible and see these events that are happening in the Middle East and think that it's resonating with the prophecies of the Old Testament.
没错。这不仅仅是基要派。我认识很多不会认为自己是基要派的主流基督徒，他们读圣经，看到中东正在发生的这些事件，认为这与旧约的预言产生了共鸣。
It's an overwhelming feature of American support for Israel. The Jewish population of the United States is not that significant. But the fundamentalist Christian and evangelical Christian population is substantial, and especially in Southern states, states where senators like Lott and Helms and so on have traditionally been great allies and friends of Israel. It's not because of their love of Jews in my opinion.
这是美国对以色列支持的一个压倒性特征。美国的犹太人口并不多。但基要派基督徒和福音派基督徒的人数却很庞大，尤其是在南部各州，像洛特和赫尔姆斯这样的参议员传统上一直是以色列伟大的盟友和朋友。在我看来，这并不是因为他们热爱犹太人。
And millions and millions of Christians give money to support Israeli causes, Jewish causes, because they believe that this is where the end times will unfold. And they have a genuine and heartfelt belief that this should happen and that it should be a part of American policy to speed that along. And indeed it is.
数以百万计的基督徒捐钱支持以色列的事业、犹太人的事业，因为他们相信末日将在那里上演。他们有一种真诚且发自内心的信念，认为这应该发生，并且将这一进程加速应该是美国政策的一部分。事实上也确实如此。
Mr. Lott, let me ask you-- how old are you, may I ask?
洛特先生，让我问你——我能问一下你多大吗？
How old am I?
我多大？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
I just turned 43.
我刚满43岁。
Do you believe that you will see the Rapture and the end time in your lifetime?
你相信你会在有生之年看到“被提”和末日吗？
I think so. I think, as fast as events are moving. And the reason I say that is because, when we began this project 10 years ago, it seemed like we began it at a very slow walk. And then it got a little faster, and it got a little faster, and it got a little faster, to the point now where we feel like we're almost running.
我想是的。我想，事件发展的速度如此之快。我之所以这么说，是因为当我们10年前开始这个项目时，似乎进展非常缓慢。然后它快了一点，又快了一点，又快了一点，到了现在，我们觉得几乎是在奔跑。
I know you have your Bible with you there in the studio. You're talking to me from Mississippi. I'm speaking to you from our studio in Chicago. Is there any passage of the Bible that you look to for strength as you do this work?
我知道你工作室里有圣经。你是在密西西比州跟我说话。我是在芝加哥的工作室跟你说话。在进行这项工作时，有没有哪段圣经经文是你寻求力量的支柱？
There's a number of scriptures. One of them that comes to mind now-- I'm turning there-- is found in Ezekiel, chapter 12. It says, "therefore say unto them, thus saith the Lord God; there shall none of my words be prolonged anymore, but the word which I have spoken shall be done, saith the Lord God." And what that is speaking to me is that God is going to fulfill every word that he has said and that he's going to do it now.
有很多经文。现在浮现在脑海中的其中一段——我正在翻看——是《以西结书》第12章。上面说：“所以，你要对他们说，主耶和华如此说：我所说的一切话，不再耽延，必成就，这是主耶和华说的。”这对我来说意味着上帝将实现他所说的每一个字，而且他现在就要做。
For years, there have been religious maniacs who have tried to blow up the Dome of the Rock and Al-Aqsa Mosque. And just last week, there was a Jewish extremist who was expelled from Jerusalem by Israeli authorities for fear that that's what he was trying to do.
多年来，一直有宗教狂热分子试图炸毁圆顶清真寺和阿克萨清真寺。就在上周，一名犹太极端分子被以色列当局驱逐出耶路撒冷，因为担心他就是想做这件事。
You know, when you talk about the inevitability of this conflict over what will be done with this site, the phrase self-fulfilling prophecy is the thing that keeps coming to my mind. It just seems like they have a prophecy about the end of the world and the end of time. And because they have it, they're putting all of the elements into place so they can have this huge argument over this religious site that could turn violent so simply and quickly.
你知道，当你谈到这个地点命运的冲突不可避免时，“自我实现的预言”这个词一直在我的脑海里打转。他们似乎对世界末日和时间的尽头有一个预言。正因为有了这个预言，他们就把所有的因素都安排到位，这样他们就可以在这个可能轻易引发暴力冲突的宗教圣地上引发巨大的争论。
Well, and they welcome that because that's prophetic. That's a fulfillment of the prophecy. So it brings on the apocalypse. That's exactly what they expect. And moreover, from the Christian point of view, they're going to be raptured and out of here before that actually happens, so they've got nothing to lose.
嗯，他们欢迎这一点，因为那是预言性的。那是预言的应验。所以它带来了启示录。这正是他们所期望的。而且，从基督徒的角度来看，在这一切真正发生之前，他们会被提到空中离开这里，所以他们没什么可失去的。
Lawrence Wright of The New Yorker and cattleman Clyde Lott. That interview was first broadcast in April of 1999. We have tried repeatedly to reach Clyde Lott and his organization to check on whether they have successfully flown cows to Israel or bred a red heifer there by now but didn't get a call back by the time of today's broadcast.
《纽约客》的劳伦斯·赖特和牧牛人克莱德·洛特。那次采访首次播出于1999年4月。我们多次尝试联系克莱德·洛特和他的组织，核实他们是否已经成功地将牛运到以色列，或者是否已经在那里培育出红母牛，但在今天节目播出时并没有收到回复。
[MUSIC - "THE LAST  ROUND-UP" BY SONS OF THE PIONEERS]
[音乐 - 先驱者之子乐队的《最后一轮》]
Act Two, The Cost of Misunderstanding. This is a true story of a group of Christians who devoted themselves to studying the Bible's prophecies about the end of the world, and about Jesus' return, a story about people who tried to live in a way that matched what it seemed the Bible was saying, and about how US government officials did not understand what the group was doing and killed 74 of them, including 21 children, when they raided their compound, the compound of the Branch Davidians, followers of David Koresh, on April 19, 1993 in Waco, Texas.
第二幕，误解的代价。这是一个真实的故事，讲述了一群基督徒致力于研究圣经关于世界末日和耶稣再临的预言，讲述了一群人试图以与圣经似乎所说相符的方式生活，以及美国政府官员如何不了解这群人在做什么，并在1993年4月19日突袭他们在德克萨斯州韦科的大卫教派大院时，杀死了其中的74人，包括21名儿童。
James Tabor is a religion professor at the University of North Carolina in Charlotte who not only followed the intricacies of what the group's leader David Koresh was saying about the Bible and its prophecies, in Koresh's final days, when he wanted to release a statement to the world explaining what he saw as the exciting news from his reading of scripture, Tabor was one of the two religious experts that Koresh wanted to give the manuscript to. Tabor sees the government's actions at the time as a tragedy of misunderstanding. FBI agents thought Koresh never discussed issues of substance with them because he was always talking to them about the Bible during negotiations. While from Koresh's view, talking about what the Bible required was explaining his position on all the relevant issues. By rolling in tanks and helicopters, Tabor says, the government unwittingly convinced David Koresh and his followers that perhaps the Bible wanted them to die in a bloody showdown in Waco, something they hadn't believed beforehand.
詹姆斯·塔伯是北卡罗来纳大学夏洛特分校的宗教教授，他不仅关注大卫教派领袖大卫·考雷什关于圣经及其预言的说法，在大卫·考雷什生命的最后几天，当他想要向世界发布一份声明，解释他从阅读经文中看到令人兴奋的消息时，塔伯是考雷什想要将手稿交给的两位宗教专家之一。塔伯认为政府当时的行动是一场误解的悲剧。联邦调查局特工认为考雷什在谈判期间总是跟他们谈论圣经，是因为他从不讨论实质性问题。而在考雷什看来，谈论圣经的要求就是解释他在所有相关问题上的立场。塔伯说，通过动用坦克和直升机，政府无意中让大卫·考雷什和他的追随者相信，或许圣经希望他们在韦科的一场血腥对决中死去，这是他们此前从未相信过的。
I think the misunderstanding of the biblical apocalyptic language of David Koresh and his followers was at the heart, really, of the whole tragedy at Waco. In other words, I don't think it needed to have ended that way.
我认为对大卫·考雷什及其追随者的圣经末世语言的误解，确实是韦科整场悲剧的核心。换句话说，我不认为事情非得那样结束。
One of the things that you write is that the government demanded that they surrender to proper authority and that when the Davidians heard that, they heard something very different than what was meant. What did the Davidians hear when they heard that?
你写道的一件事是，政府要求他们向适当的权威投降，而当大卫教派听到这个时，他们听到的与本意截然不同。大卫教派听到这番话时，他们听到了什么？
Yes. In fact, on the last day, as the tanks were inserting the tear gas all morning into the building, on a loudspeaker, there was a recording played over and over and over-- this is not an attack. We want you to come out. Come out with your hands up. Come out unarmed. Surrender to proper authority. That was the last public word spoken to the Davidians before the fire. From the Davidian point of view, it simply meant never, never could we come out under those sorts of circumstances, because obviously they believe that the only authority was God, and then David as their leader and anointed prophet. So it was just a complete crossing of wires, as we say, in terms of communication.
是的。事实上，在最后一天，当坦克整天都在往建筑物里注入催泪瓦斯时，扩音器里反复播放着一段录音——“这不是攻击。我们希望你们出来。举起手出来。不携带武器出来。向适当的权威投降。”那是大火前对大卫教派发表的最后公开言论。从大卫教派的角度来看，这意味着在那种情况下绝不可能出来，因为他们显然相信唯一的权威是上帝，然后是作为他们领袖和受膏先知的大卫。所以，用我们的话说，这完全是沟通上的错位。
Even one of the things that was usually cited as being one of the most inflammatory things to the public about the existence of his group, the fact that he had children from so many different women. Even that, there was a scriptural reason for.
甚至还有一件事通常被认为是公众对该组织存在最激进看法的原因：他拥有来自许多不同女性的孩子。即使对于这一点，也有圣经上的理由。
Yes. It's something a little difficult to justify, I think, in terms of our culture. But David did believe that he was the last and final and true prophet that God has sent to the world. And this final figure is obligated to have the seven wives, which he had, and to raise up 24 children. Now, as bizarre as that sounds, it's based upon text from the Psalms that speak about the anointed one coming, and that he will beget children, and it mentions his wives.
是的。我认为在我们的文化中，这有点难以辩解。但大卫确实相信他是上帝派往世界的最后、最终且真正的先知。而这个最终的人物有义务娶那七个妻子，他确实娶了，并抚养了24个孩子。现在，尽管这听起来很古怪，但它是基于《诗篇》中关于受膏者到来的经文，提到他将生育孩子，并提到了他的妻子们。
By explaining it, I certainly don't intend to endorse it. But the point I would make is, if you're going to deal with the group, instead of calling him a polygamist, child-molesting, sex maniac, to understand how they would have understood all of these women and their understanding of things.
通过解释它，我当然不是要支持它。但我想表达的是，如果你要处理这个组织，与其叫他一夫多妻、虐童的性狂人，不如去理解他们是如何看待所有这些女性以及他们对事情的理解的。
[MUSIC - "THE CITY SLEEPS" BY MC 900 FT JESUS]
[音乐 - MC 900 FT JESUS的《城市在沉睡》]
James Tabor is the author with Eugene Gallagher of the book Why Waco? Cults and the Battle for Religious Freedom in America. Coming up, make friends, have peace of mind, solve the problems of 20th-century Socialism, all because of the end of the world. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
詹姆斯·塔伯与尤金·加拉格尔合著了《为何是韦科？美国邪教与宗教自由之战》一书。接下来，结交朋友、获得内心的平静、解决20世纪社会主义的问题，这一切都是因为世界末日。节目继续，一分钟后回到国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, the end of the world. Today's program was first broadcast in 1999. In the first half of our show, we heard about things that we should worry about when it comes to the apocalypse. In this half-- I know it sounds strange to say-- this half of the show is all about how the end of the world can be a good thing, how it can be a good thing in the lives of people who think about it all the time. We've arrived at act three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是关于世界末日。今天的节目首播于1999年。在节目的前半部分，我们听到了关于末日时应该担心的事。在这一半——我知道这么说听起来很奇怪——节目的这一部分是关于世界末日如何能成为一件好事，它如何能给那些整天思考它的人的生活带来正面影响。我们来到了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Again. We have this story from our contributing editor Sarah Vowell.
第三幕，重来。我们有这个来自我们的特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔的故事。
Whenever I hear people talking about the end of the world, I think, the apocalypse again? I would go so far as to say that the end of the world, an event which has not happened, is the most important event of my life. I've been there not once, not twice, but three times. Here's what I can report. While the actual end of the world will, of course, involve a lot of wailing and gnashing of teeth, thinking about the end of the world can be kind of uplifting.
每当我听到人们谈论世界末日时，我想：又是世界末日？我甚至会说，世界末日——一个尚未发生的事件——是我一生中最重要的事情。我不是一次，不是两次，而是三次经历过它。这就是我可以报告的：虽然真正的世界末日当然会涉及许多哀哭和切齿，但思考世界末日却可以是一种提升。
Apocalypse one, 1970s. I've had this recurring dream since I was six years old. My mother's gone. She is not running errands gone, not at a friend's house gone. She's gone for good. Vanished. My sister's still here. My dad's around. In fact, all the kids and dads in town are present and accounted for, but all the mothers have vanished overnight. That's how I figure out the Rapture has happened. Only the women are worthy enough of God's grace to get whisked off to Heaven. The wicked men and wicked children are left to tough out Armageddon on our own. That means my sister and I will have to suffer through the lake of fire, the rivers of blood, and our father's cooking.
启示录一，1970年代。从六岁起，我就一直做这个反复出现的梦。我母亲不见了。不是那种出门办事不见了，不是去朋友家不见了。她是彻底地消失了。走了。我姐姐还在。我爸爸也在。事实上，镇上所有的孩子和父亲都在，但所有的母亲在一夜之间都消失了。这就是我推断“被提”已经发生的方式。只有女性足够配得上上帝的恩典而被带到天堂。邪恶的男人和邪恶的孩子被留下，独自面对哈米吉多顿。这意味着我和姐姐必须忍受火湖、血河，还有我父亲做的饭。
And yet, I am calm. I have my loophole, my get out of tribulation free card, which I learned about in church. I go to the supermarket, Gibson's in Muskogee, and fill a cart with food. At the checkout counter, I line up vegetables by the cash register. The clerk informs me that in order to pay for the food, I must take the mark of the beast. I refuse. Soldiers with machine guns appear. They gun me down, my blood spattering all over the salad fixins. Then poof, I'm in Heaven, dead, harp in hand.
然而，我很冷静。我有我的漏洞，我那张“免受灾难”的卡，这是我在教会学到的。我去了超市，马斯科吉的吉布森超市，装了一购物车食物。在收银台，我把蔬菜排在收银台前。店员告诉我，为了支付食物，我必须接受兽的印记。我拒绝了。拿着机关枪的士兵出现了。他们开枪打死了我，我的血溅满了沙拉配菜。然后，“砰”，我就在天堂了，死了，手里拿着竖琴。
I still have that dream sometimes. And thinking about it now as an atheistic adult, I realize how many things are going on in it, that it is a microcosm of my childhood world. At my church, Braggs Pentecostal Holiness in Braggs, Oklahoma, the sermons were about the Book of Revelation when I was in first grade, the year I learned to read. So it was the first book of the Bible I ever read myself, not to mention one of the first books I ever read period. The loophole about not accepting the mark of the beast comes from scripture, as does the grocery store setting.
我现在偶尔还会做那个梦。作为一个无神论的成年人回顾它时，我意识到梦里包含了很多东西，它是我的童年世界的缩影。我在俄克拉荷马州布拉格斯的布拉格斯五旬节圣洁教会时，一年级也就是我学会读书那年，讲道内容就是关于《启示录》。所以这是我读的第一本圣经书卷，更不用说是我读的第一本书之一了。关于不接受兽印记的漏洞来自经文，杂货店的背景也是。
According to Revelation 13:17-- "and that no man might buy or sell save he that had the mark or the name of the beast of the number of his name." And that number, of course, revealed in verse 18 is "six hundred three score and six." 666. The other reason I refuse the mark in the grocery store is tied up in the fundamentalist uproar over bar codes in the 1970s. Bar codes were thought by many to be the mark of the beast.
根据《启示录》13:17——“除了那受印记、有了兽名或有兽名数目的，都不得作买卖。”而那个数目，当然在第18节中揭示为“六百六十六”。我拒绝在杂货店打上印记的另一个原因，与1970年代基对条形码的基要派骚动有关。许多人认为条形码就是兽的印记。
Armageddon is kind of a lot to lay on a kid. The Book of Revelation is verse after verse of dragons and demons and the blood of the lamb. A typical passage-- "and the fourth angel poured out his vial upon the sun and the power was given unto him to scorch men with fire." Mom, can I have another cookie? Frankly, I could have done with more seven dwarfs and less seven seals.
哈米吉多顿对一个孩子来说太沉重了。《启示录》里充满了龙、恶魔和羔羊之血的经文。一段典型的经文——“第四位天使把碗倒在日头上，有火烤人。”妈妈，我能再吃块饼干吗？坦白说，我宁愿多看七个小矮人，少看七个印记。
But living in eastern Oklahoma, believing in the apocalypse made a lot of sense. I could buy the gaudy deaths and grisly details set forth in Revelation because Oklahoma itself was a biblical landscape. It seemed like half the year we were on tornado watch, and the place was literally crawling with snakes, snakes in my tree house, snakes on the porch, snakes in the yard. Because I was a baptized when I was eight in a water moccasin infested lake. And as if I wasn't petrified enough, fangs and drowning being two my bigger fears, Sister Minnie's drunken husband drove up in his pickup right after I came up for air, and he started scream-singing, "shall we gather at the river?"
但在俄克拉荷马州东部生活，相信末日很有道理。我能接受《启示录》中设定的俗丽死亡和阴森细节，因为俄克拉荷马州本身就是一个充满圣经色彩的景观。似乎一年中有一半时间我们都处于龙卷风警报中，那个地方简直爬满了蛇：树屋里有蛇，门廊上有蛇，院子里有蛇。因为我在一个被水蟒出没的湖里八岁受洗。好像我被吓得还不够似的，牙齿和溺水是我最大的两个恐惧，米妮修女醉酒的丈夫在我刚冒出水面呼吸时就把皮卡车开了过来，开始尖叫着唱“我们在河边聚会吗？”
Because our cousin Gary John's wife got shot dead in the head with Gary's own gun by Gary's sister's husband who was joking around and didn't know the gun was loaded. Ha-ha. Because the leader of my Brownie troop with smashed into a million pieces trying to cross the train tracks. Because my grandfather Pa Vowell buried another wife every few years. Because my other grandfather Pa Parson was a Cherokee wart doctor who could tie a string around a wart and bury the string in the ground and that made the wart go away.
因为我们表弟加里·约翰的妻子被加里自己的枪射中了头，而那是加里的姐姐的丈夫在开玩笑，不知道枪里有子弹。哈哈哈。因为我的布朗尼小队队长在穿过火车轨道时被撞成了碎片。因为我的祖父帕·沃威尔每隔几年就埋葬一个妻子。因为我的另一个祖父帕·帕森是一个切罗基族疣医生，他能用绳子系住疣，把绳子埋在土里，疣就消失了。
Because my grandmother Ma Parson lost her mind one day and couldn't remember my name, though she could remember all the words to "Bringing in the Sheaves." And today we call this Alzheimer's, but back then we called it "God's will." Because on Wednesday nights, my mother would drive this ancient witchy widow to church, a lady who believed haircuts for women were a sin, which did stop her from trimming that mangy white rope dangling off her scalp around 1923, but did not stop her from scamming rides off my mom, a hairdresser.
因为我的祖母马·帕森有一天失去了理智，记不起我的名字，尽管她能记住“把禾捆带回来”的所有歌词。今天我们称这为阿兹海默症，但那时候我们称之为“上帝的旨意”。因为在周三晚上，我母亲会载着那个古老的巫婆寡妇去教堂，一个认为女人剪头发是有罪的女士，这确实没有阻止她修剪头皮上垂下的一撮撮乱糟糟的白发，但并没有阻止她蹭我母亲——一个理发师——的车。
So in such a superstitious town among such accident-prone citizens, Revelation seemed more like gossip than a ghost story. In fact, considering all the random wrath of God around me, Armageddon appeared refreshingly well thought out. So well thought out that it included that escape clause. I was a believer.
所以在一个如此迷信的小镇，在如此容易发生意外的市民中间，《启示录》看起来更像是流言蜚语，而不是鬼故事。事实上，考虑到我周围随机的上帝之怒，哈米吉多顿显得格外精心设计。设计得非常好，以至于它包含了那个逃生条款。我是一个信徒。
But there was something stronger than my belief in God. The thing the preacher said that I believed more than anything else I heard at church was that I was a sinner. When I sang "Amazing Grace," the key phrase wasn't the title's promise of redemption but this-- "wretch like me." Even as a six-year-old, I knew I'd never be good enough to get into Heaven.
但有一种东西比我对比上帝的信仰更强大。传道人说的那些话，比我在教会听到的任何其他事情更让我相信的一点，就是我是一个罪人。当我唱“奇异恩典”时，关键短语不是标题中承诺的救赎，而是这个——“像我这样的人渣”。即使在六岁时，我也知道自己永远不够好，无法进入天堂。
So I seized on the escape clause, the idea that I could refuse the mark of the beast at a grocery store and everything would be all right. I knew I was evil. I knew I couldn't get through a lifetime adhering to daily virtue. But I was pretty sure I had the guts to stand two or three seconds of machine gun pain when the time came. And this comforted me. It kept me from panicking about the eternal consequences of every childish trespass. And so, even though it's the scariest book, Revelation did more to ease my mind than any other book of the Bible.
所以我抓住了那个逃生条款，就是我可以在杂货店拒绝兽的印记，一切都会好起来的想法。我知道我很邪恶。我知道我无法坚持一生的日常美德。但我很确定，当时间到来时，我有胆量忍受两三秒机关枪带来的痛苦。这安慰了我。它使我不必惊慌失措于每一个童年过失所带来的永恒后果。所以，尽管它是最可怕的书，《启示录》比圣经中任何其他书都更能让我安心。
Apocalypse two, 1980s. I'm not exactly proud to admit this, but I owe my life to Ronald Reagan. My family moved from Oklahoma to the pleasant college town of Bozeman, Montana in 1981, the year Reagan was inaugurated. I was 11. Away from the Bible Belt, my family was forced to attend a nondenominational church about which my mother said, "too much teachin', not enough preachin'." Religion became an increasingly less urgent part of my life.
启示录二，1980年代。承认这一点我并不怎么感到自豪，但我欠罗纳德·里根一条命。1981年，也就是里根就职那年，我们全家从俄克拉荷马州搬到了宜人的大学城蒙大拿州博兹曼。我11岁。远离圣经带，我们全家被迫参加了一个无教派的教会，我母亲称之为“教导太多，讲道太少”。宗教在我生活中变得越来越不紧迫。
This did not mean that the end of the world faded from the forefront of my psyche. I merely replaced one apocalypse for another. In the early '80s, President Reagan made so many mortifying announcements about the evil empire and his strategic defense initiative, AKA Star Wars, and "we begin bombing in five minutes," that I was utterly convinced I wasn't going to get to grow up.
这并不意味着世界末日从我精神的中心消失了。我只是用一个启示录取代了另一个。在80年代初期，里根总统发表了太多关于“邪恶帝国”和他的“战略防御计划”（又名星球大战），以及“我们在五分钟后开始轰炸”的让人毛骨悚然的声明，以至于我完全相信我没有机会长大了。
What with waking up every morning surprised there was still a world to wake up to, I was not a particularly fun-loving high school student. By junior year, 1986-- Chernobyl-- my free time was filled up with doing my homework and writing orchestra music derivative of my then-hero Philip Glass, repetitive music predicated on the notion that time perhaps is going nowhere.
每天醒来都很惊讶世界上还有一个世界可以醒来，我不是一个特别有趣的高中生。到高二，1986年——切尔诺贝利——我的业余时间都被写家庭作业和创作我当时的英雄菲利普·格拉斯风格的管弦乐填满了，这种重复的音乐基于时间也许哪里也不会去的观念。
But then my twin sister Amy, who had friends and fun and, unlike me, was an actual human being, told me that some kids she knew from art class were starting an anti-nuclear group. I was immediately excited, impressed. I only knew the kids who, like me, took band. I thought the art class kids who showed up for the first meeting of what would become Youth for Global Peace were the most glamorous people I'd ever met. They played in rock and roll bands and wrote poetry and didn't eat meat. They had spiky hair and smoked cigarettes and debated whether or not William Burroughs' Junkie was better than his Naked Lunch.
但后来我双胞胎姐姐艾米——她有朋友，有乐趣，不像我，是一个真正的人——告诉我，她美术课的一些朋友正在组建一个反核小组。我立刻兴奋起来，印象深刻。我只认识那些像我一样参加乐队的孩子。我认为那些出现在后来成为“全球和平青年”组织第一次会议上的美术课孩子们是我见过的最迷人的人。他们玩摇滚乐队，写诗，不吃肉。他们留着尖刺头，抽烟，争论威廉·巴勒斯的《瘾君子》是否比《裸体午餐》更好。
Yeah, yeah. We talked about nukes. We were against them. We'd meet every Saturday night at Greta Montaine's house. We handed out pie graphs of Reagan's 1986 federal budget, in which defense spending was the biggest slice of pie, at grocery store parking lots. We got up really early one morning and plastered the school walls with xeroxed posters of a mushroom cloud on which we had scribbled, "this could happen to you."
是啊，是啊。我们谈论核武器。我们反对它们。我们每周六晚上在格蕾塔·蒙泰恩家聚会。我们在杂货店停车场发放里根1986年联邦预算的饼图，其中国防开支是最大的一块饼。一天早上我们起得很早，在学校墙上贴满了蘑菇云的复印海报，并在上面乱写：“这可能会发生在你身上。”
My biggest moment was probably representing the group on a round table discussion on the local public television channel. The adults said a few mundane things about a saner nuclear policy before I started screaming, "you got to grow up! Do you know what it's like to think you're not going to grow up? Do you?"
我最大的时刻大概是在当地公共电视频道的圆桌讨论中代表该小组。大人们在讨论更理智的核政策时说了几句平淡无奇的话，然后我就开始尖叫：“你们得长大！你们知道以为自己长不大是什么感觉吗？你们知道吗？”
In retrospect, the anti-nuclear part of the anti-nuclear group was the least important thing about it. I had had friends before them, but I had never had a gang, never had a group of people I liked and admired and enjoyed. The anti-nuke group taught me a lesson which changed my life-- how to hang out. And the first time Matt Brewer, the coolest boy, invited me over to his house, and I got there, and he and Jimmy Harkin were sitting around listening to Black Sabbath and spray-painting Legos black, I sort of hugged myself, contrary to conventional leftist wisdom, with nuclear arms. I didn't know life could be that fun.
回想起来，反核小组中“反核”的部分是它最不重要的一点。在那之前我也有朋友，但我从未有过一个帮派，从未有过一群我喜欢、钦佩并享受其中的人。反核小组给了我一个改变我一生的教训——如何一起混。当马特·布鲁尔——最酷的男孩——第一次邀请我去他家时，我去了，他和吉米·哈金坐在一起听黑色安息日乐队的歌，把乐高积木喷成黑色，我不禁拥抱了自己，这与传统的左翼观点相反，是用核武器。我不知道生活可以那么有趣。
Apocalypse three, 1990s. Berlin Wall falls. Cold War ends. I start believing I might live long enough to die of something other than a first-strike Soviet attack or refusing the mark of the beast. Goodbye darkness, my old friend.
启示录三，1990年代。柏林墙倒塌。冷战结束。我开始相信我可能会活得足够长，去死于苏联第一次打击或拒绝兽印记以外的其他原因。再见，黑暗，我的老朋友。
Ah, the good old days. When I was a kid, the end of the world really was something, nuclear holocaust, the Rapture. But they don't make apocalypses like they used to. Just look at the cheap little cataclysm they're trying to pass off to unsuspecting future-phobes lately. These kids today and their Y2K. Do they know what it's like to think they're not going to grow up? Do they?
啊，美好的旧时光。当我还是个孩子时，世界末日确实是一回事：核大屠杀，被提。但他们制造的启示录不再像以前那样了。看看最近他们试图卖给毫无戒心的未来恐惧症患者的那些廉价的小灾难。这些今天的孩子们和他们的Y2K。他们知道以为自己长不大是什么感觉吗？他们知道吗？
To find out, I traveled to San Francisco. I heard about a community group there which was organizing for the possible Y2K aftermath. The good people of BAY2K were not the young, Silicon Valley computer programmers I'd hoped for. Instead, the group felt very ex-hippie, very new age, very Marin. One part of the evening ended with a women reciting a Hopi prayer.
为了找出答案，我去了旧金山。我听说那里有一个社区团体正在为可能的Y2K后果做组织工作。BAY2K的好人们并不是我所希望的硅谷年轻程序员。相反，这个团体给人的感觉非常前嬉皮士、非常新纪元、非常马林。晚会的一个部分是以一位女性背诵霍皮语祈祷结束的。
They broke down into small groups to address specific problems, from pragmatic topics like community preparedness to the less tangible psychological and spiritual issues. They admit it could be that, come January 1, nothing will happen. This is how Y2K differs from previous apocalypses. The old ones, we knew exactly what would happen, we just didn't know the date. Y2K, we know the date. It's what'll happen that's up in the air. One woman says that if nothing happens on January 1, well, at least she had a good excuse to meet her neighbors and have a really good dialogue.
他们分成小组讨论具体问题，从社区准备等务实话题到心理和精神等不那么具体的问题。他们承认有可能到了1月1日，什么都不会发生。这就是Y2K与以前的启示录的不同之处。以前的那些，我们确切知道会发生什么，只是不知道日期。Y2K，我们知道日期。至于会发生什么，还悬而未决。一位女士说，如果1月1日什么都没发生，好吧，至少她有一个很好的借口来见见邻居，进行一次非常好的对话。
Which in a certain sense seemed to be the point. Just like my old church and my old anti-nuke group, they're using the end of the world as a means to meet and greet, planning block parties so they can come up with Y2K contingency plans in their neighborhoods. They were also very idealistic. This is the thing you might not realize about end of the worlders. They might seem like they're all about fetishizing doom and destruction, but stick around long enough for them to finish their spiel-- few people do, I know-- and before long, they get to a straight-up Utopian vision of the world. After all, after the biblical tribulation comes the new Jerusalem and 1,000 years of peace on Earth.
从某种意义上说，这似乎就是目的。就像我以前的教会和我以前的反核小组一样，他们把世界末日作为一种见面和打招呼的方式，计划街区聚会，这样他们就可以在社区里制定Y2K应急计划。他们也非常理想主义。这是你可能没意识到的关于“世界末日论者”的一点。他们可能看起来都在迷恋厄运和毁灭，但只要你待得够久，等他们说完——我知道很少有人这样做——没过多久，他们就会得出一个直白的乌托邦愿景。毕竟，在圣经的大灾难之后是新耶路撒冷和地球上的1000年和平。
The BAY2K activists said they saw the possible societal shut down as an opportunity for community building. They talked about how American culture is unsustainable, out of control, optimistically opining that we brought this all on ourselves. They're looking forward to a saner, more agrarian way of life. One of the men said neighborhoods should get together and buy a tiller to start community gardens. To them, Y2K looks a lot like Y1K.
BAY2K的积极分子说，他们将可能的社会崩溃视为社区建设的机会。他们谈到美国文化是不可持续的，失控的，乐观地认为这一切都是我们自找的。他们期待着一种更理智、更农业化的生活方式。其中一名男子说，邻居们应该聚在一起买一台耕耘机来开辟社区花园。对他们来说，Y2K看起来很像Y1K。
I grew increasingly alarmed at the picture they were painting, a golden picture of neighbor with neighbor throwing off the shackles of Capitalism to till the soil at one with the Earth. A woman named Leslie said she'd like to help out but, "I'm physically challenged so I can't even offer my strength. I can't garden. I'd like to, but I can't." [? Nityama, ?] the man sitting next to her, tells her that she could contribute in other ways, like canning. He says, "even the know-how of doing it is just as valuable as the manpower or the strength to do it."
我越来越担心他们描绘的画面：邻居与邻居摆脱资本主义的枷锁，与大地合一耕耘土地的金色图景。一个名叫莱斯利的女人说她想帮忙，但“我是残疾人，所以我甚至无法提供我的体力。我不能耕种。我想，但我不能。”坐在她旁边的男子告诉她，她可以以其他方式贡献，比如罐头制作。他说，“即使是制作的方法也和人力或体力一样宝贵。”
Aw, each giving according to his abilities, each taking according to his needs. I'm not sure which thing I react to more, this brand of shiny, happy Marxism all expressed as if the history of the 20th century never happened or the talk about canning. Just picturing Mason jars full of stewed tomatoes, a bomb goes off inside me. I suddenly realize what they're proposing. Canning, gardening, spending time with your neighbors. This is Oklahoma minus God, the one thing that gave it all some dignity.
噢，各尽所能，各取所需。我不确定我对什么反应更强烈：这种闪亮的、快乐的马克思主义，表达得好像20世纪的历史从未发生过一样；还是关于罐头制作的谈话。仅仅是想象一下装满炖番茄的梅森罐子，我内心就发生了一场爆炸。我突然意识到他们在提议什么。罐头制作、园艺、和邻居花时间在一起。这是俄克拉荷马州，减去上帝——那是赋予这一切尊严的唯一东西。
They're welcome to their millennial vision, to whatever gives them hope. I too have imagined a Heaven on Earth, a new Jerusalem that comforts me in times of tribulation. Behold my Revelation, I stand at the door in the morning and lo, there is a newspaper in sight like unto an emerald. And holy, holy, holy is the coffee, which was and is and is to come. And hark, I hear the voice of an angel round about the radio saying, "since my baby left me I found a new place to dwell."
他们欢迎他们的千年愿景，欢迎任何给他们希望的东西。我也曾想象过一个人间天堂，一个在新耶路撒冷中安慰我度过大灾难的愿景。看我的《启示录》：早晨我站在门口，看，视野中有一份像祖母绿一样的报纸。圣哉、圣哉、圣哉是那咖啡，它是过去、现在、未来。我听到天使环绕收音机的声音说：“自从我的宝贝离开我，我找到了一个新的居所。”
After this, I beheld, and lo, a great multitude which no man could number of shoes. And after these things, I will hasten unto a taxicab and to a theater, where a ticket will be given unto me. And lo, it is a matinee and a film that doeth great wonders. And when it is finished, the heavens will open and out cometh a rain fragrant as myrrh. And yea, I have an umbrella.
在此之后，我看见，看，一大群多得数不清的鞋子。在此之后，我将赶往出租车，赶往剧院，在那里我将得到一张票。看，那是日场，是一部行奇事的电影。当它结束时，天堂会打开，飘出像没药一样芬芳的雨。是的，我有一把伞。
Sarah Vowell is the author of Take the Cannoli: Stories from the New World , where a version of this story now appears.
萨拉·沃威尔是《带上奶油甜馅煎饼卷：新世界的故事》一书的作者，这个故事的一个版本现在出现在书中。
[MUSIC - "MODERN WORLD" BY THE MODERN LOVERS]
[音乐 - 现代恋人乐队的《现代世界》]
Act Four, None Shall Know the Exact Day or Hour. The logical conclusion to believing that the end of the world is coming, to thinking about it, to preparing for it, is finally trying to compute when exactly it will happen in advance. We are a nation where many Christians have tried to do exactly that throughout our history. Somebody who's trying today is Bonnie Gaunt. She lives in Jackson, Michigan. Some of her calculations are based on the fact that every Hebrew letter corresponds to a number. So the Hebrew text of the Bible is filled with numbers that provide clues to the date of the Rapture and the end time. She's written nine books about this.
第四幕，无人知晓确切的日子或时辰。相信世界末日即将来临、思考它、为它做准备的逻辑结论，最终是试图提前计算出它确切会在何时发生。我们是一个历史上许多基督徒都试图做这件事的国家。今天尝试的人之一是邦妮·冈特。她住在密歇根州的杰克逊。她的一些计算基于每个希伯来字母对应一个数字这一事实。因此，圣经的希伯来文文本充满了为“被提”和末日日期提供线索的数字。她已经为此写了九本书。
Bonnie Gaunt also points to scripture that indicates that the millennium will come on the sixth biblical day. Each biblical day, she says, is 1,000 years. And you start counting from the creation of Adam. Counting all the events in the Bible and since, she believes that she has discovered the exact day that good Christians will be raptured directly to Heaven and that the end time will begin.
邦妮·冈特还指出经文表明千年期将在第六个圣经日到来。她说，每一个圣经日是1000年。你从亚当的创造开始计算。计算圣经中的所有事件以及之后发生的事情，她相信她发现了虔诚的基督徒将直接被提升到天堂和末日将开始的确切日期。
I spoke with her back in April of 1999. And at that time, her calculations indicated that the exact date of the Rapture would be--
我在1999年4月采访了她。当时，她的计算表明“被提”的确切日期是——
September 11, 1999.
1999年9月11日。
And has it affected your behavior in daily life?
这影响了你日常生活中的行为吗？
Yes, that's very true. Such as our house is in desperate need of siding, new siding on it. And my husband says, well, when spring comes, let's put siding on the house. And I says, well, let's wait until after September 11 to put siding on the house. If we're not raptured, then maybe the house needs siding.
是的，这是真的。比如我们的房子迫切需要外墙板，新的外墙板。我丈夫说：“好吧，等春天到了，我们就给房子装上外墙板。”我说：“好吧，让我们等到9月11日之后再装。”如果我们没有被提，那么也许房子确实需要外墙板。
And there are things like when I get catalogs in the mail for clothes and shoes and this kind of stuff, and I look through the catalogs, and I toss the catalog down, I says, what am I looking in this for? What do I need new clothes for? I don't need any new clothes between now and the Rapture. I don't need any new shoes. I can wear what I've got.
还有一些事，比如我收到邮寄的衣服和鞋子目录，我翻阅目录时，我把目录扔在一边，心想：我查这些干什么？我需要新衣服吗？从现在到被提之间我不需要任何新衣服。我不需要任何新鞋子。我可以穿我现有的。
You know, I would think it could also go the other way. You would think, OK, well, after September, I'm going to be gone. So I can have the extra dessert. Do you know what I mean?
你知道，我觉得这也可以反着来。你会想：“好的，9月之后，我就走了。所以我可以多吃一份甜点。”你知道我的意思吗？
I hadn't even thought of that. I had thought strictly in the other concept that I don't need these things because I'm going to be given something so much better. I guess what I'm attempting to do is prepare for it, but also still prepare to keep on living in case my date is wrong, in case the date that I have is not correct. I have told my sons, prepared both of my sons for the possibility that their father and mother might disappear.
我甚至没想过那个。我严格考虑的是另一个概念，因为我不需要这些东西，因为我将得到好得多的东西。我想我正在努力为它做准备，但同时也准备好继续生活，以防我的日期错了，以防我得到的日期不准确。我已经告诉了我的儿子们，为他们的父母可能消失的可能性做了心理准备。
And what were these conversations like with your sons? I would imagine that, if they're not believers in the same way that you are, that could be kind of a hard conversation to have.
你和儿子们的这些谈话是什么样的？我想，如果他们不像你那样是信徒，那将是一场很难进行的谈话。
Well, they were very kind and polite to me. What they were really feeling inside was not revealed on the outside. The 38-year-old, when I was telling him all this, and he just sat there with this big grin on his face and this sparkle in his eye. And I couldn't tell whether he was happy for me because I had such a beautiful hope or whether he was secretly laughing at me. I don't know.
嗯，他们对我非常友善和礼貌。他们内心真实的感受并没有在脸上流露出来。38岁的那个在告诉他所有这一切时，他只是坐在那儿，脸上带着大大的笑容，眼里闪烁着光芒。我不知道他是因为我拥有如此美丽的希望而为我高兴，还是在暗中嘲笑我。我不知道。
How much of your time, how much of your thinking does it consume?
这消耗了你多少时间，多少思考？
I can think of little else. I go out for a walk and I talk with God and I'm just so anxious to see Him and to be in His realm. It's just such a beautiful, living hope for me that that hope is with me all day long. I lie in bed at night and think about it. And it's a beautiful hope.
除了它，我几乎想不了别的。我出去散步，我与上帝交谈，我太渴望见到他并进入他的境界了。对我来说，这是一个如此美丽的、活泼的希望，这个希望整天伴随着我。我晚上躺在床上思考它。这是一个美丽的希望。
It's difficult because people have been predicting the return of the Lord for centuries. And even the early church, the early church thought he was going to return in their day. So I have people telling me, well, why do you think your date's any different than anybody else's date? None of them have ever come true. So how do you know yours is going to come true? I don't know that it is. I'm hoping that it is.
这很困难，因为几个世纪以来人们一直在预测主的再临。即使是早期教会，早期教会也认为他会在他们那一代回来。所以我有人告诉我：“好吧，为什么你认为你的日期比别人的日期有什么不同？他们从来没有成真过。所以你怎么知道你的会成真？”我不知道它会不会成真。我希望它会成真。
Marilyn Agee lives in California. Like Bonnie Gaunt, she studies Bible prophecy and has tried to compute the length of all the events in the Bible to figure out when the end time would begin. She's the author of three books on this subject. The latest is Heaven Found . Last year, she set a date for the Rapture, May 31, Pentecost.
玛丽莲·阿吉住在加州。像邦妮·冈特一样，她研究圣经预言，并试图计算圣经中所有事件的长度，以找出末日何时开始。她是三本关于此主题书的作者。最新的一本是《天堂发现》。去年，她设定了一个“被提”的日期：5月31日，五旬节。
What did you do the day before? That must've been such a momentous day.
前一天你做了什么？那一定是一个极其重大的日子。
I have a web page up called Bible Prophecy Corner. And I answered email constantly. I was answering email. And I meant to stay up all night because the Jews stay up all night. And my back hurt so bad-- I live in pain. I have lots of pain. So it hurt so bad I went to lay down just for a few minutes, just to rest my back, and was going to go back and answer email, left my computer on and everything. And I woke up in my clothes the next morning. I didn't get a chance to stay up all night. I hope I can do better this time. I want to stay up.
我建立了一个名为“圣经预言角”的网页。我一直在回复邮件。我在回复邮件。我本打算整晚不睡，因为犹太人整晚都不睡。我的背痛得太厉害了——我生活在痛苦中。我有太多的痛苦。所以它痛得太厉害了，我躺下休息了几分钟，只是为了缓解背痛，本来打算回去继续回复邮件，电脑也没关什么的。第二天早上我穿着衣服醒来了。我没能整晚不睡。希望这次我能做得更好。我想熬夜。
Did anybody try to stay awake with you?
有人试图和你一起熬夜吗？
No. Uh-uh.
没有。嗯-嗯。
Like Jesus in the garden.
就像花园里的耶稣一样。
Yeah, they couldn't stay awake. And I couldn't either. And I meant to. I really meant to.
是啊，他们也坚持不住。我也一样。我本打算的。我真的打算的。
And when you woke up, what was that like?
当你醒来时，那是什么感觉？
Well, I just knew it didn't happen. So back to the drawing board. What is there there, what clue is there there that I didn't see?
好吧，我只是知道它没发生。所以回到绘图板。那里有什么线索是我没看到的？
You must have been so, so disappointed that morning.
那天早上你一定非常、非常失望。
Oh, of course. Because I've been counting on it since 1969. But you know something? I wasn't cast down, and my faith is so strong there's no possible way that it could interfere with that. Nothing. They could kill me and I wouldn't give an inch, you know.
噢，当然。因为我从1969年就开始指望它了。但你知道吗？我没有被打倒，我的信仰如此坚定，没有任何可能干涉到它。没有。他们杀了我，我也不会退缩，你知道。
Do you think there's anything that you'll miss about Earth?
你认为有什么关于地球的事情会让你怀念吗？
Not much. Things are getting so bad here, and I have so much pain here, and I think how nice it will be to have a day without pain. I haven't had a day without pain since I was 30 years old and I'm 70.
没多少。这里的事情变得越来越糟，我在这里有太多的痛苦，我想如果没有痛苦的一天该多好。自从我30岁以来，我没过过一天没有痛苦的日子，我现在70岁了。
You were saying before that you have back pain.
你刚才说你有背痛。
Oh, I have muscular spasms, and they can hit anywhere. I was awake two times the night with my feet cramping just last night. I had to take quinine and Motrin.
噢，我有肌肉痉挛，它们可能会在任何地方发作。昨晚我有两次痛醒，脚抽筋。我不得不服用奎宁和布洛芬。
And so after the Rapture?
那么在被提之后？
After the Rapture, I won't have any more pain. That will be nice.
在被提之后，我不会再有任何痛苦了。那会很好。
Marilyn Agee has re-calculated her chronology since our interview back in 1999. She now believes that the rapture will occur on Pentecost of this year, which is May 28.
玛丽莲·阿吉自我们1999年的采访以来重新计算了她的年表。她现在相信被提将发生在今年的五旬节，也就是5月28日。
Let's close our program today with this last artifact. In 1818, a farmer in New England named William Miller spent two years studying scripture, especially a passage in Daniel that Marilyn Agee, in fact, pays a lot of attention to, Daniel 8:14. And William Miller concluded from his reading that the Rapture and the end of the world would happen in the year 1843. Many people, including mainstream clerics, became convinced that his calculations were sound and a whole movement started up.
让我们以最后一个文物结束今天的节目。1818年，新英格兰的一位农民名叫威廉·米勒，花了两年时间研究经文，特别是《但以理书》中的一段经文——事实上，玛丽莲·阿吉对此非常关注——即《但以理书》8:14。威廉·米勒从他的阅读中得出结论，“被提”和世界末日将发生在1843年。许多人，包括主流教会人士，确信他的计算是合理的，一场完整的运动由此开始。
And when 1843 came and went without the end of the world, he recalculated, set a date for 1844. This time, the anticipation was even more excited. Scholars who study the Millerites a century later noted dryly that, when people are committed to a set of beliefs, clear contrary evidence may simply result in them holding to their beliefs even more firmly.
而当1843年过去，世界末日并未来临时，他重新计算，设定了一个1844年的日期。这一次，期待更加激动。一个世纪后研究米勒派的学者冷冷地指出，当人们致力于一套信仰时，明确的反面证据可能只会导致他们更坚定地坚持自己的信仰。
And that's what happened in this case. All over New England, farmers didn't plant. Others planted but did not harvest as testament to their faith that the world would in fact end. And on the appointed date, October 22, 1844, when the sun rose and set on another ordinary day in New England, a Millerite wrote, "our fondest hopes and expectations were blasted and such a weeping came over us as I have never experienced before. It seemed that the loss of all earthly friends could be no comparison. We wept and wept until the day dawned. My advent experience had been the richest and brightest of all my Christian experiences. If this had proved a failure, what was the rest of my Christian experience worth? Has the Bible proved a failure? Is there no God, no Heaven, no golden home city, no paradise? Is all this but a cunningly devised fable? Is there no reality to our fondest hope and expectation of these things? And thus, we had something to grieve and weep over if all our fond hopes were lost. And as I said, we wept till the day dawned."
这就是在这个案例中发生的事情。整个新英格兰的农民都没有耕种。其他人耕种了却没有收获，作为他们信仰世界确实会结束的证明。在约定的日期，1844年10月22日，当太阳在新英格兰的另一个平凡日子里升起和落下时，一位米勒派教徒写道：“我们最美好的希望和期待被摧毁了，一种我从未经历过的哀哭笼罩了我们。这似乎与失去所有尘世的朋友相比都无法相提并论。我们哭啊哭，直到黎明。我的降临经历是我所有基督徒经历中最丰富、最明亮的。如果这证明是失败的，那我其余的基督徒经历还有什么价值？圣经证明是失败的吗？没有上帝，没有天堂，没有黄金家园，没有天堂吗？这一切难道只是一个精心编造的寓言吗？我们对这些事情最美好的希望和期待难道没有现实意义吗？因此，如果所有的希望都破灭了，我们有东西可以悲伤和哭泣。正如我所说的，我们哭到黎明。”
The world is going to end. The world is going to end. So if you're going to love me, you should hurry.
世界末日了。世界末日了。所以如果你要爱我，你就该抓紧了。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好了，我们今天的节目是由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。乔治·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯提供了制作帮助。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，号码是312-832-3380。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who you can find any day of the week, wandering the hallways of WBEZ singing this song--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，你可以在一周的任何一天在WBEZ的走廊里看到他，唱着这首歌——
"Shall we gather at the river?"
“我们在河边聚会吗？”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。